and there's a remark that I want to
start with from book two
Aristotle tells us
um and this is rackham's translation
again let it be granted to begin with
this is in chapter two that the whole
theory of conduct is bound to be an
outline only and not an exact system in
accordance with the rule we laid down at
the beginning this is in chapter in book
one that philosophical theories must
only be required to correspond to their
subject matter and matters of conduct
and expediency have nothing fixed or
invariable about them any more than do
matters of Health now what is he saying
there he's telling us that ethics and
other philosophical matters are not
going to have the kind of you know cut
and dried it's either this way or this
way and we can be definitively sure
about it in every single case and give
you know rules for it as we might say
for mathematics
um we're dealing with particulars we're
dealing with things that are complicated
human nature is complicated what we can
do is provide as he says outlines tupos
in Greek right and so we have to if you
ever had one of those you know coloring
books as a kid or you know now they have
these adult coloring books for people
with anxiety or things like that
um you've got the outlines and then you
have to put in the the colors that's the
way it works with this sort of stuff
when it comes to Virtue ethics there are
not a hard and fast no exceptions set of
rules that we
can provide and anybody who claims to
provide those to you is uh not actually
doing virtue ethics they're they're
doing something quite different does
that mean that it's like anything goes
no we we can certainly you know have
some guidance Aristotle has some clear
ideas about you know what a virtue looks
like as opposed to Vices
but we we have to take responsibility
for filling in the outlines so that's
that's quite important
really key here as we're going to see in
other sections is the mean the middle
and Aristotle's basic idea
is that things are made bad by too much
or too little is often translated as
excess or deficiency we can say well too
much or too little of what well lots of
different things as as we'll see but you
know
if you he uses the example of you know
for example the body
um eat too much not good for you eat too
little not good for you you want to be
just right in the Goldilocks sort of
thing if you're familiar with the
Goldilocks story she breaks into the
bear's house
um she's not a very good person this
Goldilocks and you know she tastes some
porridge some porridge is too hot she
you know takes a little bite and then
leaves it alone something's too cold
some is just right same thing with
chairs same thing with beds and all of
these sorts of things
well virtue and this is kind of you know
the Goldilocks thing is a silly trivial
story but virtue is that that middle
section
so if you think about anger for example
and this goes back to that that question
that uh that Nicole was asking before
about stoics and aristotelians
um the stoics said anger is always bad
Aristotle who's predating the stoics by
the way says no no you should get angry
to the right amount at the right time
and we can go on and on and on and he
also says this is this is difficult to
do
um by the way if any of you are into you
know the whole emotional intelligence
movement Daniel Goldman begins his first
book emotional intelligence with that
quotation from Aristotle where he is
um saying uh it's difficult to get angry
to the right amount with the right
person for the right time etc etc etc
right so
um this is you know this is an important
Point things are are
made good by being in the middle they're
screwed up by by going to excess or
deficiency
he tells us in chapter seven that the
coward at one extreme the rash at
another extreme and the courageous in
the middle are concerned with the same
matters or stuff but they're differently
disposed towards these and and what are
these so there's really two answers to
this
fearful things or situations the the
stuff out there that were actually
feeling fear or confidence in relation
to so you know if I'm afraid of uh
spiders or bees or something like that
those are objects of fear right if I'm
lying awake at night and not sure if I'm
going to be able to you know speak well
at the conference that I'm going to that
that's an object of fear as well right
one is more imagined one is right in
front of me and then there's the
feelings that we have right
um so fear is something that we actually
feel and and many of us feel it at
specific parts of our body right
confidence is is sort of the the
opposite or the uh Converse of fear you
know what it's like when you go into a
situation and you feel you know a sense
of like being you know on top of things
and these two
um you know are are what courage and
these other vices are concerned with so
Where Do We Go Wrong
um he says error arises either from
fearing what one ought not to fear the
wrong thing right or from fearing in the
wrong manner fearing the wrong way or at
the wrong time and then he's got
Aristotle loves these hey something like
that you know uh these sort of
catch-alls right uh he says and you know
those other things something of that
sort and then he says similarly with
respect to confidence so you know you
remember back to right person right
amount right time these are all coming
up in the virtuous mean and the vicious
um extremes and so what is temperance or
what is moderation
so he says the observation of the mean
when it comes to pleasures and he says
that it's concerned in a lesser degree
and not the same manner with pains and
we should also think here about desire
about about appetite or epithumia in in
Greek right the desires for these
pleasures
and he tells us that it's going to have
to do with pleasures of the body most
specifically those of eating and
drinking and sex Pleasures that we share
with the lower non-rational animals and
this is where we're probably going to
want to expand Aristotle's point of view
a little bit so he he begins by
distinguishing Pleasures this is in
chapter 10 of book three
and why is he doing this he wants to
help us zero in
on what pleasures and what desires for
those pleasures
are really involved in Temperance
he thinks that not all of them are so he
begins by talking about Pleasures or
desires of the Soul
um for example philotinial ambition
something we're going to look at later
on in in a couple weeks love of learning
philomatha right enjoy the sort of thing
that's motivating all of you to be here
right now
um loving to hear marvelous Tales right
being entertained right uh I think
watching things on Netflix would would
figure into this gossiping
talking about you know what's going on
with our neighbors and he says
Temperance and self-indulgence or
prodigality is how the the vice uh
aqualastia is often translated
Temperance and self-indulgence don't
bear on these things there there's other
things other virtues or vices that have
to do with those
Okay so we've got
pleasures of the Mind Over Here
pleasures of the body
what about these pleasures of the body
here's where Aristotle says stuff that
we might not agree with
Temperance doesn't concern the pleasures
of the eyes
although these can be enjoyed too much
or too little or in the right manner
what's an example of the pleasures of
the eyes
looking at paintings
again
watching shows on streaming platforms
like Netflix or HBO uh Max or Amazon
Prime or pick whatever else you want
sitting in the movie theater watching
movies right it could be
um you know
looking at paintings or whatever else
you want
so Aristotle says okay that's not
Temperance what about hearing listening
to music right or smell he talks about
loving the smell of roses or perfumes or
savory dishes
in our time we might think about people
who have essential oils or buy candles
right to make the air smell a certain
way or you know I made chili yesterday
and every time we walk into the
apartment you can smell the the spices
and the tomatoes and the beans and all
that sort of stuff right that's there's
pleasure involved in that
but that doesn't concern temperance
and so
what does okay we've we've eliminated
three of the senses right Vision hearing
smell what do we got left taste and
touch
so he even says taste plays a small part
and this is something that I I just find
incredible for him to say but we'll look
at the argument
he says for the self-indulgent it's not
the flavor of the food but it's the
touch that provides the pleasure The
Filling yourself up with it right
and we could think about this in terms
of food we could think about this in
terms of is he says drink which you know
would would include wine which would
include intoxication or or sex right and
so the things that we actually do
um wind up being temperate or
self-indulgent with are primarily
pleasures of food
intoxication or or are you know sexual
organs and activities and stuff like
that they all involve touch according to
him
so you notice that Aristotle discusses
anger in the nick of McCain ethics in
the passages that you know I pointed out
to you
um it's not a very long discussion and
you know you kind of wish that he'd
written more
um same thing with the udamian ethics
where he also discusses this and
um
you know rhetoric book two there's a big
long discussion of anger and calmness
but it's from a different point of view
and there's no single place in
Aristotle's Works where there is the
definitive position on anger you kind of
have to take you know like a bit here
and a bit here and a bit here and piece
it all together and that makes sense
because Aristotle tells us in on the
soul the day anima
that anger he uses this as an example
will be understood from different points
of view so for example the foosikos the
natural philosopher will understand
anger primarily in bodily terms as
boiling of blood around the heart right
because that's where Aristotle thought
that thinking took place a lot of
ancients thought that and they thought
that the blood played a really Central
role in this you know somatic function
um so that's one way to look at it
another way is what the dialecticos the
the philosopher the the person
investigating things psychologically
would say and then he would Define it in
a different way as
um you know a desire for retaliating
right
um so there's different different levels
you could say or different ways of
looking at anger so in rhetoric book two
um Aristotle has a discussion of anger
and of the emotion that's opposed to it
or the lack of anger proutes and he's
using that word there not to denote The
Virtue but just a a condition an
emotional condition of calmness and he
defines anger there and it's a very
complicated definition this is part of
what makes Aristotle's work on this so
attractive so he says that anger is a
desire or axis in Greek we just talked
about that a little bit earlier
accompanied by pain matalupes pain or
don't think physical pain thinks
psychological pain think
disturbance being upset all right so now
we've got two parts of it desire
accompanied by pain what is the desire
after this goes to that question does
anger have an object yes it has a very
general object
apparent retribution retribution
now timurias is coming from the word for
uh honor or social status
is sort of like a restoration of the
social status that has been taken from
one that
um was damaged that was lowered in some
respect you you set things right that
you know you uh Rectify things the
phenomenase means a parent or imagined
this is very very important so people
are looking when they're angry for
something that we could translate as
public retribution or imaginary
retribution or a parent retribution kind
of in the middle something that they can
take as being retribution even if the
other person isn't so you might have
somebody who you know tries to insult
somebody else and they're not really
really insulted by it and they do that
because they're angry with the person
and the other person is like whatever
dude you know I don't care what you
think and
um that can be retribution for the first
person who's like I got you man I really
zinged you so you know it really uh
matters this uh
you could say subjectivity that's
involved there this isn't the whole
thing though so we've got desire for
Retribution apparent retribution
accompanied by pain what causes it here
he tells us in the definition
aroused by an apparent sliding once
again we see that word apparent in there
Dia phenomenon
so sliding is you know literally making
something less
you know treating it as as uh lesser
value and again we see it can be
apparent so you can get mad at me even
though I didn't do anything that should
have made you mad if you take me to be
sliding you
to be treating you in in a certain way
and there's one other part to well
actually there's two other parts to this
so one part is the sliding is against
oneself or those connected to oneself so
it could be your friends it could be
your family as we're going to see it
could also be philosophy it could be
your sports team it could be anybody
that you think matters and you don't
like people saying or doing bad things
to them
then the last part that's really
important the sliding being undeserved
to Ole goren me proseccontos being
unbefitting not not being how things
ought to be so I mean if you think that
the sliding that you're getting is
actually deserved you don't get angry
you have to think that it is wrong in
some sense it's unjust it's unfair it's
it's uh making you know an exception for
that person or making an exception of
you
and
there's one other part to it that's not
in the definition but I think is also an
important moving part of this there's
pleasure and anger too
we've all felt this I think at one point
Aristotle says there's pleasure in
taking retribution so when you're
actually doing the retribution you're
doing the action or statement or
whatever it is you you feel good you
know you hang up the phone back in the
old days we used to have you know phones
that you could like slam the receiver
down now of course you all you could do
is like you know hit your phone hard to
turn it off right I'm gonna hang up on
you right
um that feels good there's there's a
pleasure involved in that some people
get pleasure in imagining or
anticipating the Revenge the retaliation
that they're going to take and that
might actually be something that they
they get you know a little bit too
involved in and it it promotes Vice
right
um so the mean notice what the
difficulties are
how one is angry in Greek toe posts the
manner in which you're angry so you know
let's pause on that for a minute
actually let's think about each of these
in turn
when we talk about uh in our
contemporary parlance you know the
difference between
expressing yourself and your emotions
assertively and expressing them
aggressively that's part of that how
right
um getting angry at somebody so for
example we were at a conference or not a
conference a concert just the other day
and we're you know as an outdoor uh
concert and my wife was laying down she
had her head covered up so she could
take a little nap because we got there
you know many hours ahead of time it's
Alpine Valley it takes a long time to
get in and get out so we you know rode a
bus there and there was a guy a bunch of
guys that were kind of talking together
and
um
you know one was getting a little bit
too close and so I said to him and I
chose my terms quite carefully I said
Hey kid you're like one step away from
kicking my wife in the head
and he like looked down and he got you
know apologetic and moved away
and I I said it with kind of a sharpness
to my tone and I was kind of getting you
know who is this jackass who's like not
paying attention to where he's actually
walking
but you know it was expressed in a way
that was essentially assertive with an
edge not you know hey jackass get the
hell away from here right that would be
this is part of the how right you can
express your anger within certain limits
we can say certain rationally discovered
limits
um so that's the how with whom one is
angry in Greek TC the the person that
the anger is directed at
oftentimes we get angry with the wrong
person right
um if you go to the Department of Motor
Vehicles or whatever it's called in your
place you can expect to wait in a line
and you can get angry about having to
wait in the line why the hell don't they
have more clerks up here to handle the
stuff right and you get to the front and
then you like blow up at the person I
can't believe I had to wait half an hour
in line to deal with this
they don't control that you know they're
not the right person to get angry with
or you know the boss at the company
enact some new policy that's stupid and
you blow up at your co-worker This is BS
they they're not making the policy right
they're not the ones that are
threatening or sliding you in any way so
that's important too right
um on what grounds epipoise
what are you getting riled up about what
are you getting angry over this is a big
question too there are some things that
shouldn't make us angry and then there
are some things that should make us
angry right and many people
get confused about them if if somebody
comes along and you know I think that um
uh Iron Maiden is a great band right uh
you know I I if you were to ask me when
I was a kid what's the best band in the
world I would have said Iron Maiden uh
through most of my teenage years and
then into my 20s
um if somebody comes along and they're
like Iron Maiden sucks
should I be getting angry about that
does that really make sense is that
rational you know that I let some some
Joe blow off the street come along and
and spout some nonsense you know
um probably not that that's that's a bad
reason to get angry
um
how long once we are angry how long do
we remain angry
do we let things go or do we hold
grudges forever until we get the
retaliation that we want right or the
satisfaction we sometimes say
okay that's that's that's a viable
question
um and then uh up to what point one is
right or errors in being angry Aristotle
says at one point
um there are some again there are some
times when we shouldn't be angry and
then there's other times where we should
in this discussion first of generosity
he says that wealth or property we have
an observance of the mean the mesotace
the middle position in relation to
wealth and here he says something really
really important
he says we call Wealth all those things
that we can measure monetarily in Greek
hey oxia uh no no no Miss mati Metra
time so haoxia is the value of of the
thing right it's the worth of the thing
and uh no Miss mati is the dative of uh
nomisma
um money and Metro that's the word we
get metrics from right to measure so
what can we measure
um what Falls within this scope so we've
got money itself right and I don't have
my wallet here but it doesn't matter
anyway because I don't have any dollar
bills in my wallet because I don't carry
cash anymore back some of you may have
seen videos of me like when I would talk
about this and I'd pull out a dollar
bill or something when I was teaching at
Marist College
um currency is is a type of wealth
um property
this iPhone you know I don't know what
it's worth now it's an iPhone 10 so I
mean it was like a thousand bucks when
we bought it we measured that with money
right
I'm sure it's worth much less now
um so its measure has gone down
um this uh
SIM card that I've got right here that I
use for my video stuff this water bottle
right uh it's sort of like if you've
ever seen the movie Dr Detroit uh which
is a very trippy movie from the 1970s a
comedy there's this scene where a person
is having a terrible Nightmare and
there's somebody else Who's acting in
kind of a phantasma magoric horrific way
and he's saying all for sale all for
sale well it means that it's being
measured in money and then you know the
terrible thing about that is the it is
he says not my mother and then it's even
your mother you know so long as you can
put a dollar amount on it or whatever
it's going to be you know uh Swiss
Francs uh Euros yeah it's got It's got
some monetary value
and if you think about our time right so
we have money that you might have in the
bank your income uh financial
instruments and Investments you know our
pensions if we have them or retirement
accounts
um which are you know buying stocks and
bonds and you know things like that
these are all these are all kind of
imaginary right but they are things that
we say have Financial value
um on the internet people pay money for
likes or subscribers or platforms or
data or people will even pay money for
opportunities and experience and in
economics they use this notion of
willingness to pay what would you pay to
have a one percent less chance of
getting sick you know they send out
questionnaires to people
all of this is stuff that Aristotle
would say in our time can be measured
monetarily and I think that we could
measure our time
um and our energy and our thought and
our attention in certain ways as well
right maybe maybe not reliably but it
all falls within the scope of this so
let's talk about the virtuous mean
virtue is always going to be a mean for
Aristotle
what does this look like for generosity
and so he says that you know again this
is kind of generic it is observance of
the mean with respect to giving and
taking of wealth so there's these two
sides right
but there's more to that
um
we could say the generous person gives
on account of something hennika in Greek
right and this is a term that I think
you've heard me use before like if we go
back to the very first session the on
account of the motive the reasoning why
is the the person giving in order to
accomplish something good fine Noble
honorable he also says that they give
rightly orthos the word that we get you
know like orthogonal from right
um straightly uh in the right way and
we're gonna there's gonna be a couple
specifications to this and we'll look at
those in turn
um so
the generous person will be doing what
giving this shouldn't be any surprise to
anybody giving to the right people right
so the people that they should
the right amount this is very very
important you know you're not generous
if you're like writing out checks for a
million bucks to everybody that I mean
that might be something different it's
probably going to be being a spend
thrifter prodigal
um you give at the right time you don't
have to give all the time but there's
certain situations that maybe demand it
a little bit more
[Music]
um
what else the other conditions of right
giving as he says
is Right giving and ta'ala is the others
and then hepatit means follows those
that that follow upon right giving so
what would this extend to like you know
not just at the right time not just the
right amount but in the right way you
know it's one thing if you give money to
somebody and you do it and you're kind
of snide and snarky and you're like yeah
I hope you don't spend it on booze yeah
you know dirty degenerate that's not
being generous right to give that to say
a homeless person
um if you can give in such a way as to
you know not lower them in in their eyes
and your eyes that probably would fall
under there I expect
um let's talk about magnificence so
we're shifting we're shifting topic here
slightly we're kind of going upscale
um this is a virtue that uh maybe not
all of us can actually participate in
and develop because we don't have the
resources to do this I mean you could
say well what about time you can always
give time
we all get the same 24 hours a day you
know and I I mean I use about seven to
eight of mine and just sleeping you know
and then there's always like a couple
that I spend on screwing off watching TV
shows or stuff like that you know uh so
so time can't produce magnificence but
wealth can't
so
Aristotle says in order for
um us to be magnificent
it's going to have to do with the
spending of wealth on a larger scale
and the greatness of scale he tells us
is relative it's think of that as like
you can go past a certain threshold and
then there can be like lowercase M
magnificence an uppercase M magnificence
and in all capitals magnificence and it
really depends on the you know the
resources that you have and what you're
doing with it so he says that an outlay
for outfitting a tri reamer Galley for
the Navy is not great in comparison for
equipping a state pilgrimage a state
pilgrimage is all these people going to
a holy site and I guess that's more
expensive like on a scale of magnitude
um over equipping a tri-room but we just
kind of have to take Aristotle's word
for granted for that but we could think
in our own time about like um
you know my wife and I have looked at um
the idea of creating a scholarship
um at Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design and you gotta you gotta come up
with quite a bit of money for that and
that's a lot of money for us but it
would not be a lot of money for
Jeff Bezos he could like you know
basically sneeze and create you know a
million scholarships and he'd be just
fine right so there's different scales
involved here and he says that it's uh
spending on great matters or or things
you know and the the he also says
something really interesting here
the magnificent person in order to be
magnificent
they have to be
um you know the translation here in
Rackham is they have to be an artist but
that's kind of a a mistranslation they
have to be knowledgeable uh epistemonies
it's coming from the word for for
knowledge epistemate right they have to
be knowledgeable in expenditure and
Aristotle gives us two criteria for it
he says that they have to be able to
discern literally see theore side or
like think of
what is appropriate Prepon and this is
where you know Megalo prepaya this is
where we're getting that from the
parapon is what is appropriate what what
is befitting and he also says they can
spend great sums with good taste in
Greek and Melos that's an adverb there
so I mean you all know people who spend
lots of money you know they they
proverbially make it rain but it's not
in good taste right
um they're doing it in ways that are
demeaning to other people or show that
they're just trying to be a big shot
that's not yet magnificence
so what else goes into this
um he tells us that the object produced
is again how the translate or the the
deed the doing the ergon must be worth
the expenditure the dapane the money
you're spending
and he uses that word oxia there again
so we've got a a value term
and then he says the expenditure must be
worthy of or exceed the object itself so
the object has to be one that's worth
spending money on
um the money that you spend has to at
least match or exceed the thing that
you're you're trying to do
it's an interesting way to put it I I
think uh the next thing that he tells us
is that the motive the hennika right is
doing something Noble doing something
good
so you know if I think about our own
city right here
um we might when I say we my wife and I
often go to the Milwaukee Symphony
Orchestra which is just several blocks
from here and we are really really
fortunate to have a wonderful Symphony
that has some Stellar
um musicians some of whom have been
there for decades a great composer and
guest composer we have amazing artists
come in we get to hear these these
world-class performances taking place
just several blocks from us and that
exists because
rich people spent money on it right I
mean we didn't uh we buy you tickets but
we're we're not like you know shelling
out you know a million bucks or
something like that
um somebody did
and it's it's got you know one of the
most acoustically advanced uh music
halls in there with all of this
wonderful stuff during the uh covid
pandemic they were broadcasting live
performances with all these mics
everywhere and and cameras and cool
stuff like that that is something Noble
uh and you could say well wait a second
what if you're not into classical music
well it doesn't have to be Noble for
everybody it doesn't have to be
something that everybody gets into I
mean you could also give money to
um children's uh drama performances or
to preserving the many wonderful parks
that we're we're fortunate to have here
in Milwaukee due to our our socialist
past a lot of the Germans of 1848
brought their socialist ideas like poor
people should have access to Nature to
this uh this uh area and as a result we
have much more green space than other
cities our size
um all of that could be a matter of of
magnificence all of that could be where
the motive was the the noble